tous les cas dimanche la france va
donner au président de la république une
large majorité
c'est d'ailleurs une logique des
institutions n'a souvent dit que depuis
la réforme du quinquennat
c'était la réplique sismique de
l'élection présidentielle disons que sur
l'échelle de richter
c'est une réplique est forte oui mais la
démocratie c'est aussi à côté d'une
majorité stable et clair une opposition
responsable qui propose et une
opposition qui parfois doit aussi au
delà du contrôle s'opposer mais qu'il
doit rester d'abord est ce que vous
pensez possible rééquilibrage décidé
dimanche je pense que ce rééquilibrage
c'est ça la notion du sursaut est
nécessaire y compris pour la réussite du
quinquennat d'emmanuel macro comment ça
parce que je le dire je compare souvent
ça à la pelote basque il faut un fronton
parfois pour renvoyer les balles et pour
construire dans le pays
il faut toujours que le débat ait lieu
au parlement sinon ça se termine dans la
rue et c'était une des inquiétudes que
j'avais exprimé chez les à vos confrères
la semaine dernière